it's time for pop quest
[Applause]
hi elena all right where is ayanna
nathaniel oh there you go
you've been selected
hi
you got those heels on you can't run you
got some nice legs two you're so
beautiful
okay
hi
how are you oh we're great how are you
i'm fantastic i'm so glad to be here
you're looking fantastic we feel the
same way thank you
okay i hear you're a bit of a true
gooder is this true will you tell us
about it i am actually i'm the founder
of a nonprofit organization it's called
dear to dream leaders inc and we're
based in brooklyn new york i help middle
school students thank you
i empower middle school and high school
students and our motto is what would you
do if you knew you could not fail and we
empower them to dream big
[Applause]
what would you do if you knew you could
not fail i love that anything right yeah
why did you decide to do this with your
life i grew up in east flatbush and i
seen children and youth going down the
wrong path so it's something that i said
i needed to be a part of the solution
not the problem so i decided to create
something in my own backyard
[Applause]
[Music]
i think every question right needs to be
a thousand dollars today
[Applause]
okay this is where i start getting sick
to my stomach are you ready
i think so all right here we go all
right three thousand dollars on the line
all right first question
meghan trainor and her husband have side
by side once twilight
megan says she and her husband actor
daryl sabara have side by side his and
her toilets
[Applause]
and again for the record i love meghan
trainor please come on this show
all right you know she's from nantucket
really she's i i love her focus okay i'm
focused second question fame composer
andrew lloyd webber is still traumatized
by a movie based on one of his musicals
what was the movie cat
the famous broadway composer recently
revealed he had to get an emotional
support animal
after seeing the movie cats
[Applause]
final question name one of the weird
food combos that we tried with tick-tock
star ayton bernath today watermelon and
mustard
this was a crazy viral thing on tick
tock where people were putting mustard
on their watermelon
thank you
[Applause]
thank you so
us you're such much good person thank
you for doing everything you do thank
you so much thank you for having me
[Applause]
thank you all for choosing to spend your
time with us we make this show for you
so take this good energy with you
and we'll see you tomorrow
[Music]